ladies and gentlemen first time in too
long I think Jim Breuer this was my gym
every single night during the Metallica
tour yeah me and they had these guys
guys this crew males females genders the
whole ship big oh who knows who knows
who knows and I'm not even kidding there
was it's another whole story just beings
yes there are beings yeah every night we
would go by the soundboard and we would
lip-sync and bang our heads hard to this
song to the point where when the tour
was over it was about 20 of us in a
circle in the back and head filled with
seed after a while mm-hmm and he just
started laughing he start throwing pics
at us for the crowd
yeah that's gotta be awesome for
Metallica though because it's one thing
for you right because you're on tour
with Metallica you're doing comedy
before they come out it's like a
once-in-a-lifetime deal but for the crew
this is what they do so the idea that
Metallica is so good that the crew is
actually like not only enjoying the show
but with the fans these were fans oh so
you just went out with the fans always
every single night you're done with your
part of the show I'm doing my part of
the show I can just go I would go by the
sound board oh I thought you meant you
were behind the scenes with the sound
board oh no no no no no so there was a
railing and I'd be by the sound board
yeah and the way this started it was a
there was a Korean guy names Korean
James okay right and and he's he's he's
by himself dancing and what frustrates
me if I go see Metallica everyone now is
reserved and we don't know how to act
because we have children and and where
we have a job where we are corporate
world and we've been working to just you
don't show emotion in this life anymore
you're adults for God's sake you don't
speak off the chalk that we told you to
read from it's right really directory
and use intelligent words represent us
well when Metallica is based on a primal
we used to go in my friends basement and
just blend
Metallica Slam of just headbang hard in
each other's faces and so I missed that
going these concerts right and well also
- it hurts after a while that's why I
can't do is this age right that's the
other thing about getting older it's
like not only do they say you're not
supposed to do it your body says you're
not supposed to honey goes let's take it
down you have two IPAs in you and you're
not thinking this kid this kid's guy is
going nutso and I went up to him and he
sees me his eyes light eyes like wall
right what are you what are you doing
here what do you want stick and I went
line for line with Ganges and then we
did three straight songs and I need to
pass out after that and then all of a
sudden it literally became a tradition
every single night to the point where if
they weren't playing this song and they
were playing an obscure song which they
haven't played they'd all run to the
round pointed me and go come on yeah
come on come on they're doing damage it
you gotta come out and then I would come
out dude it was I became a fanboy in the
car it was the greatest thing ever that
is that meanness and that's that's how
you that's the reason to do stuff like
that right because what you did was Jim
Breuer goes out there and you know you
said not opening because I listened to
you talk about no not hate opening for
Metallica but you're going out you're
doing a little bit of comedy you're
interacting with the audience you're
doing you're doing stuff you're just
being kind of an emcee that's reasoning
I was in emcee for the night everybody
right but realistically you're doing the
emcee part so that you can just go to
every single Metallica show on this tour
and get paid and get paid get paid and
so by the end of the tour because that's
what people always ask right by the end
of the tour last show on the tour you're
still sitting there going holy [ __ ] I'm
going to a Metallica show and getting
paid for it again yeah that's amazing I
have to say I'm not lying
hands down mm-hmm whatever I'd done in
my career this was the greatest gig ever
had in my entire lifetime so were you
depressed after it ended or were you
like okay you know what that's gonna be
my
this is my moment this tour you know the
whole tour it's just a time that's gonna
I'm always gonna be able to live and
reflect on that that's how I look at ya
because I've learned that already from
years ago sure you know even even a year
ago moments in time no matter how big
it's just like the radio show right you
come on and you have the biggest guest
come on here and it's the greatest show
and people still talking about months
later but you still here on Thursday
going I know do we have here eat up
another four hours you're not now in
Rolling Stone magazine you know that
anyone the greatest show ever now you're
making a billion dollar it doesn't you
know it's just a moment in time right
and you got a grasp that moment in time
sit back enjoy it enjoy it reflect on it
know you're in it right and know that
it's gonna end you have to know it's
gonna end yeah and you have to know amen
I'm not expecting anything to happen
from this just it's just this is what it
is that's key right not the sort of like
oh this is great and it could lead to
this and could lead to that you just go
this is great end of sentence and that's
what I had people out there with me and
you know as friends really you know
people I think you can be so now listen
it just doesn't work that way if if some
fans now discovered oh wow it's funny
his videos are funny and let's go see
him I definitely see more Metallica
shirts in my audience there you go and
but like you said the purpose wasn't to
get Metallica fans to your show the
purpose was I get to go on tour with
Metallica that's the purpose if you told
me in in 1986 I'm showing up snot rocket
high mm-hmm drinking like a jackass at
18 19 18 years old to see Ozzy a metalic
is opening up and I knew them I was
still scared by them you were yeah yeah
I was scared you know my friends too
get me into as I can listen to this and
I put on the headphones he's like you
got us in this track and the first song
I heard was for Whom the Bell Tolls and
you know 1985 year and I ran and then
look to the sky just before you die it's
the last time you will cuz I'm creeping
dead die die
yeah you're going I know you're
celebrating I go around here we go in a
war so I think of that moment I can
literally I remember everything about
that moment watching them and I felt I
was crazy to compare but almost perhaps
the way people felt when the first time
they saw the Beatles live they knew
something different was happening when I
saw Metallica that night and the way
people reacted and what's going on right
people are nuts right now and this the
arena was no one's no one's in there for
opening band court and I feel like they
blew Ozzy Ozzy that was on the side you
follow this throwing chairs not so I
mean and then now I'm torn
it's crazy weird what do you think it is
about Metallica because I think about
them sometimes they're they're an
exception to almost every role in the
sense that there are a lot of metal
bands from the era that stay on tour in
some way shape or form whether it's
festivals whether it's whatever and that
core audience that they established
they'll follow them and they'll still do
it but Metallica is completely separated
from them to the point where like I'm
not a metal fan per se I'm not going to
any festivals I don't care about any of
these old metal bands but if you tell me
you got tickets to a Metallica show hell
yeah
you know I mean well because they
there's listen those bands from that era
and the metal bands and all that
they they don't as you know they have
rabbits I don't want to piss any of
their friends off they don't grow I see
alright it's almost like seeing that kid
from high school did you're really
trying to grow your hair to your
shoulders your bald on top right you're
still singing about the dragons and
stuff coming it's like when you let your
afro stay even though it's creeping to
the back yo
we're Metallica for me it now became me
Metallica's I can honestly say almost
like my best friend that had my life
that that made me think about faith but
mind control war vanity it made me sit
and think I would read the lyrics you
know I discovered my dad through
Metallica like cuz I always wanted to
know what is what did my father go
through and war and you know and you'd
hear songs you listen to textbooks and
learn in school but you're right and the
thing of a soldier and I look at songs
like disposable heroes and you look at
the lines of at the end the day a
soldier is in battle and the guys going
you will do what I say when I say get
back in the front and you will die when
I say you must die back in the front you
coward you servant you blind man back in
the front 21 only son
I always served as well oh my god yeah
that's that that is that's real right
the leper Messiah about church and
organized religion it was just it was
everything they wrote about came from
somewhere where and it wasn't like hey
I'm in love and nothing wrong with that
music there's plenty of that everywhere
right um
I can't stand Hollywood I can't stand
vanity I can't stew that's what
started four right you wanted it I
wanted it bad until you saw it but I saw
it and I lived it yeah I I can't stand
any of you I can't stand the scene
go back to Jersey it's up gone one of
your Long Island but my wife's like now
and we're gonna make Jersey damn it damn
it fine we'll go to New Jersey and and
that songs like moth into the flame
which is all about pop culture
sad but true was me constantly being
tempted by manager I knew is evil mm-hmm
and just always like you know you should
do this and taking your ideas and don't
you want this all its it was they meant
something more than like oh this is a
great riff right totally now is it so is
that what you did is that do you go like
you're you're you're chasing Fame SNL
movies whatever it is and then do you go
you know what I gotta stop chasing this
carrot that everybody's chasing and just
start doing the stuff that has a kid I
would have freaked out if I told you
adult me would be doing because it seems
like you took that turn liked it I
definitely took that turn it's not like
Metallica
you you going on tour with Metallica
it's not like it's the first time that
something like that has happened for you
know like you've gotten to associate
with pretty much all your heroes yeah
which is crazy amazing it is amazing I
remember being a kid on Jefferson Avenue
long gown that was me and my friend Phil
I'm still best friends with and Jean and
I remember saying I'm gonna be a star
I'm gonna work with Jack Nicholson and
Joe Pesci and De Niro and I'm gonna be
hanging out with the Mets and my
favorite bands in the world and in my
mind I think you know this summer Jim
Breuer sir or and like I'm landing in my
backyard and then there was a time where
even now I sit back and I call my guys I
did everything I said I was gonna do I
just didn't do it the way I
visualized it but it did happen right
and it's almost like the world goes
alright
are you satisfied yet right here it is
this is what you wanted right
well gave it to you now what are you
satisfied you need more like what's
gonna right and when it really started
hitting for me my first my first world
was uptown comedy club and that was more
of a real life's in their people support
each other was the Uptown cut it was was
people say hey I was your big break the
break was Senate live but my life break
was uptown comedy club and then SNL I
just saw Hollywood at its at its peak
and bands like wow it really is just a
show this person you know the Farley
thing really I was I was really taken
back by that I saw that week of him
coming the hosts and what a mess he was
and I was I see I was taught I could not
believe Mitch Hedberg ever these are the
guys that you would look at and be like
wow that's what I'm going for right well
no I could not believe the trouble they
were in yeah and no one in their team
mmm no one in their team took the time
to go when you're not you know working
right so what was more valuable your
money collecting from them or putting
them in the limelight or ratings or
whatever and that was really disturbing
to me
so that's what kind of started to turn
you off Hollywood is when you saw like
even though these people have no
business performing they need help yes
they're getting milked for every dollar
that everybody can get out of and and I
just have people god yeah yeah it's
gonna be fun yeah that's gonna fight you
and I'm walking around S&S so and I
always thought to myself would would my
friend Phil would my brother they'd walk
in there and go hey [ __ ] all you right
you're coming with it and they know you
don't know [ __ ] get in the car [ __ ]
kidnapping dude dude do you see what's
going on with you yeah and the fact that
and it still happens where I've seen it
Hedberg I watched him and I I remember
going up to him like hey man I remember
calling his people hey I would like to
take this guy out on tour man he's a
really good we go I'm gonna get it for
the Vani reason but you can't see the
problem he had right new right hey you
didn't you didn't stop that you didn't
but you're just trying to get him on
stage tomorrow we'll figure out the rest
of it though just get on stage that
stage okay here's the minute like that
is to me really dark and disturbing
right and so is vanity really what you
know and you look at the stars out there
today some of them are just hey I got
famous because I bang someone at
videotaping
so now pornography is how you become a
star mm-hmm which if that's you think
great but if you're great at it okay
your skill that's great yeah but anyone
out there that's a parent you're gonna
tell me you're okay which is 17 year old
kid now and that's your idol yeah I mean
that's that's the like you have to you
have to kind of watch out for that when
people there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be successful you wanting to
be the best at what you do wondering
even if it means fame comes with it yeah
but when you see people that just famous
like my goal is to be famous that's when
it's trouble yeah like you know the
people we idolize right I delight if you
take I don't even know who's in People
magazine right I don't read anything
anymore I don't tapped out so if you
whoever's on there let's say it's a
great name like Tom Cruise okay if Tom
Cruise was my brother I go listen here
my brother he's a [ __ ] mess he seizes
he's on his 20th marriage he's got 14
kids all over [ __ ] play itself
[ __ ] mess but we see past all oh yes
owner oh yeah it does amazing work and I
think he's one of the best of our time
but as a the people my family that are
on their third fourth marriage I'm just
like what are you doing man just get you
look at your kid your kids on opioids
because he's cuz you're not around and
you don't know who his mother is and I
was a half mother and what are you doing
what are you doing yeah you kind of get
away from the foundation
how about your a father first right
mother and I'm I'm not preaching I'm
just saying that's not the world I want
to be part of that's not the world I
grew up in and I don't wanna I don't
wanna
so so what do you find it like you start
focus you go home and then you start
focusing on your family and you're
focusing on the things that you just
actually like that you're naturally
drawn to and then all of a sudden yeah
that's what starts to be around you not
so for me Sam the first ten years and I
see what every I see with every end a
lot of entertainers but me you start off
because you want the leather I call it
the leather pants and kangaroo syndrome
you want the leather pants you want the
kangaroo walk around the mall people go
oh of course
after 2001 ish mm-hmm
then as I start a family I saw when torn
and I came here to satellite because I
realized ooh
the more my way there's a little trouble
at home I was you know my wife's gets
two kids she's the one I can't do this
so I took a job here this is this is
like when serious was just starting to
take off yeah this is before anyone was
here yes so it came here I'm like hey
yeah I'd love to do a radio show I don't
know what it's about right but uh I kind
of want to bring my best friends I grew
up with and we're just gonna talk and
hang and and that's what we did as a
brick so but the real drive behind that
was so I could be home and then in 2008
I wanted to start over again doing just
stand up and and controlling my destiny
instead of hey you should be doing this
gonna move to LA you go you should go
for the show you should do it alright
what do you what do you really want I
just I start off as a comedian in high
school and things went quick for me but
I still was running frantically and the
minute I stopped looking for that I said
you know what I'm just I'm okay I got a
I got a beautiful home a great kids life
as well I make good money what am i
chasing for why do why do I got to look
at what this guy
making what this guy's doing and what
how come he's the batter and the minute
the minute all that's gone II just look
at what's in front of you they just
focus on you and passion that's when
life started really getting good for Jim
Breuer world what was it was the first
thing that happened in that era where
you were like yeah this is really cool
um I'm gonna say one of the first ones
was the well there was a couple there's
my dad right right I went on tour 2008
to that and brought my father always
brought my father business the first
time I filmed it hmm and that although
it was funny I was really taken back by
the amount of people it's that were
touched and inspired that's that's what
they were did I wanted to get high with
you and I saw you at your dad you
talking about your kids and [ __ ] you
made a family I didn't think I could do
that but if you could do it I can do it
and I I started seeing more and more
like hey man I never I never liked you
but what you did what your family I
really respect it now and and hey I my
father never said he loved him and I
could not believe it was bigger than
just being funny right it touched lives
wow this feels so much better but this
is this is what I did off stage anyway
right usually don't realize throw it
throw a camera on it let the world know
this is what's going on behind the
scenes and it's more interesting than
what's on stage half the time and it
wasn't even my intention right tension
was I want to make little I always try
to stay ahead of the curve I'm like okay
I want to make little website videos and
put on Jim Breuer calm and here's how
funny my dad is and then that came and
then the other I'm gonna say one of the
big breaks was those Metz videos that's
it who do I mean I'm just going on
complaining about the mats on Facebook
and or celebrating celebrating this guy
let's go to bubble butt and next thing
you know a man you're sold out what
[ __ ]
how many people would miss shirts in the
audience what's going on and even like
everything every it's busy I really feel
like I'm freaking Forrest Gump of
entertainment it's not yeah you're
getting to the point where you are I
think it's almost it's comical to me I
look back like well you know this time
last year I'm gonna stage a Billy Joel
that's what I was thinking about so I
was thinking I'm like you've literally
performed with Billy Joel like what is
that like I sang with Brian Johnson of
ac/dc saying with Brian Johnson Sanka
I sang a song with them not live huh huh
but one of my favorite parts of that
tour was and I feel like I was I've been
auditioning since I was 18 for this
moment so they're in Nashville yeah and
before they start every new leg they
were going to the arena and they would
rehearse with just them and their crew
and I would always walk in because I
never get tired of it and I bust balls I
dropped my drawers and trying to moon
them and throw off their there too and
then so they're playing and James goes
alright I'm done and Lars goes dude
can't we just we just do one more song
could we do wherever I may roll and
James goes now I'm done because come on
man just one more and he goes Jim you
come on up if Jim comes up here does it
okay wait wait why life is quite
distorted so I went up and they put the
lyrics for wherever I may roam on this
little thing and now now I'm singing
like oh this is my big audition right
you talk about going forward you're
going like well if they like me and
Billy Joel you know I'm a seasoned
veteran of this clearly they know about
me by now and I I grab the mic and I'm
waiting for the moment and it's a big
long build-up that song and it starts
off with like
and the and the road becomes my road and
I it's not out in social media anywhere
because they have it and they gave it to
me but I'm like it's it's not for
everyone to see
okay that's just your own personal you
have the video though for yourself on me
yeah yeah yeah and there is part of me
I'm like guys I put a DVD player it's on
Facebook I don't know I call head feel I
change you know my kids Dora and put it
out there to show snapchat now I'm so
sorry this is out there nothing we can
do now guys though I'm gonna go ahead
put on my you do not that we could do it
now five billion hits I again I sang it
like oh yeah this is my big audition and
it really it was just have fun and while
I was up there is trying to graphs the
moment of I'm with my friends but I'm
also singing with the band right I'm I'm
singing with them but no matter how
close you get to them as human beings
you can't forget the fact that you're
just a kid singing with Metallica that's
it yes yeah and then and the funniest
part was um I didn't see it whatever and
people can't who were the guy was with
this other comedian Josip goes bro just
use video and now because the best part
is when you look at Kirk and Rob the
bassist and the lead guitars when you
started they both looked at each other
when it was just you got to live those
moments and those moments are so there's
such amazing blips of time and and
that's all we got you know I want to be
I'm gonna be a nine-year-old guy or do
you know crap my pants knowing what's up
talking about waitress that could give
two shits and I was singing forever
every I'm a room well yeah oh yeah
scrambled his James and then and then
they brought me up cuz I still owe you
know maybe don't bring me on the live
concert but that did happen but there
was this Korean James fella and we said
withdrew all night okay we went
hashbrowns and of course in your 90 year
old state you're convinced that you're
still telling these stories with the
same energy and detail that you didn't
write you don't there's no difference
and then she's behind the counter now
and I'm still talking
and then there's no one in the arena it
was just me and my friends and they
rehearsing okay yeah I was yeah it's
pretty cool
that's great man are there more I mean
are there checklist moments that you
still have because I feel like I'm
thinking I'm thinking about all the
stories that I've either heard you say
on the air that we've talked about on
the air that yeah about there is one
what else is there there's one I'd this
is crazy my lifetime dream was to be
able to sell out not the garden Nassau
Coliseum Uniondale as a comedian as a
comedian yeah tickets gone sell Jim
Breuer Long Island you're sold out yeah
Nassau Coliseum I don't even need to do
a tour just a one show just that one
show sold out Nassau Coliseum not
through Groupon for one not like hey if
you're an outer ticket holder you get to
see Jim for free they paid and wanted to
see me live at that show and I just give
the performance of a lifetime which I go
out of my way to do all the time for
anyway because I love it but that I know
it sounds good that's always been my
dream that's it that's it I would love
to sell out Nassau Coliseum well you
like is there any disappointment cuz I
don't know have you you've talked about
the Foo Fighters thing on the air before
I heard yeah because what scenario is so
great regardless
that hurt that hurt you talking about I
bring my nephew to go see the Foo
Fighters this is after you're on stage
with Billy Joyce's after I already
crushed the Billy Joel shook me all
night long which Foo Fighters have no
clue right nobody knows really you've
got that confidence in you guys yeah Jim
for those that don't know went on stage
with Billy Joel yes and saying shook me
all night long and and it was rocking
nature we were in one supposed to happen
right right not supposed to happen I
brought my daughter she wanted tickets
50th anniversary next thing you know you
want to meet him I only got two vodkas
in me and before the next thing you know
I meet him and he goes uh
hey I heard you to ac/dc Wow yeah I oh
you want to do HDC tonight why and I and
I said and if you don't know the story
long story short I said I I'm not gonna
remember the words anyone I well do it
another time and we'll rehearse and
figure it out another time and once you
come and early meet the band and
rehearse and we'll do another time okay
his guitarist Tommy Burns then finds me
in another room my wife and kid goes
Breuer you doing yeah I do tonight oh I
don't know
I'm gonna forget the lyrics he's like
this monitors all over the stage big let
if you go by if you go by Billy's pianos
big letters that say sing me a song I
know you're not gonna forget it you got
to do it tonight and then he I said he
wanted me to rehearse and he left the
room came back goes he says cool we're
doing it and then as you know over ten
songs and went oh my god I couldn't
remember the song so I get under my belt
crush it life is great right for that
moment right when the moments over I'm
still staying line with forty people
waiting for my car at the garage
oh my god this is correct you're just
standing just in line there's number 32
in line you can't go anywhere can't go
anywhere I'm waiting for my Ford Escort
to pull up they're all disappointed when
my car pulled through you're driving of
course they're just reality is gonna
come smashing down on them yeah the next
morning my kids yelling at me my wife's
going you didn't put the sticker on the
trash at 7:00 the more he goes so 7:00
it's over back to the moment is the
moment so now is the Foo Fighters yeah I
know Chris the guitarist sure and Chris
I came I got you all access pass come
backstage okay I'm not gonna tell my
nephew he's gonna flip out how old's
your nephew he's 16
big deal and he's a huge guitar player
all he does is sit home play guitar he's
a Foo Fighter maniac he can I keep
trying to push in them it's not that he
just started okay just started I think
he'll get there he is he's like let's do
really hard to play good I'm glad you
recognized that so once he learns how to
play it since it's hard to play if he
learns it it'll be all he wants to play
cuz it's like you know I mean that's
always gonna want to play exactly
Metallica you learn them and it's on so
um we walk in and the first person we
sees Dave Grohl I've never met Dave I'm
a little like huh Wow
let's Dave okay yeah he's in that rock
God category that's a big rock guy right
there that's uh Taylor I've met great
guy hung out with him talking he's I so
see him and he said we think about Dave
Grohl though is nirvana tacked on to Foo
Fighters right it's got a hell of a rock
Dave Grohl yes
enough said yes and my nephew just oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] right to his face I'm gonna
I said Eric take it down a level phase
like I said for Oh shits to his face
it's right there okay let's walk over
here and whereby we're eating and then
he's going holy [ __ ] stop saying that
just you're here live the moment Dave
Grohl then comes walking over to me now
part of me too is like now he's been
around Jack Black and these guys really
know how to rock and he's see I'm just a
meathead to him he comes over he goes
dude dude
first thing Dave girl says to me when
Brian Johnson wasn't doing ac/dc
I was like Brewers gotta do a Stu Brewer
has to be I want stop it stop it he's no
good I said can I just say I went on
every radio station and I said I would
not go see ac/dc unless David Grohl was
singing I go that would that would be
legit to me Dave grosses hey Brian can't
be here but I'm filling in because I
love ac/dc boom ah man I'm so I'm a
follow the whole tour because he's the
guy I'm Sifu fighters I'm not looking
for the glamour I'm just I'm here to
fill in I would the Dave girl to me she
on them should have been a guy now with
that said he has a couple course lights
does everyone they're getting ready to
go on stage and he goes hey man you want
to come up do let there be rock with us
tonight Madison Square Garden now I was
hoping he say shook me night huh so but
let there be rock makes a lot more sense
and I did this with Taylor at a festival
okay he asked me say hey man you want to
come up with us we kind of went it's the
rest of the Foo Fighters and we do like
these cover songs and and I did it with
him we're in Houston and I got up and
from the crowd and but when when Dave
asked me I went uh-oh man I don't know
if I remember the lyrics he goes come on
man you know layers
I used to happen in front of me he's
going in the beginning back in 1955 now
in that moment right there is that great
just to watch a musical genius start to
just just doing that just holding a beat
like all I'm thinking about it's like
I'm not gonna remember the worst
there's no matter how much he tries it's
not gonna happen
he doesn't have the Billy Joel magic he
does and and monitors well yeah he and I
said yeah in the white man has a stir in
the play he went III will do another
time
never mind and went wait wait wait now I
want to do it Billy Joel actor now he
goes like a wait wait wait wait wait
wait um Tim monitors and he looked at me
as if that was the craziest question of
the best moment because what do you mean
monitors I went what whatever and I said
it's so nonchalant I said well when I
sang when I say it would I go when I
sang with Billy Joel
he had the saw he had the song in the
monitor and he looked he went when he
sang it with Billy Joel he's so confused
you don't know if I'm being pompous I
read so many things in his eyes like
because there's just something about
that statement that like brought you
like we were having fun a minute ago
what are you doing will you just try
Billy Joel from me talking about like
and you actually are pretty good and
that's kind of where the fun is but
you're not you know what are you talking
about roll what do we you know we people
wouldn't what's going on with you bro
monitors - hey Billy Joel like is the
water not right in the dressing room
what are you talking about you have all
access like 10 minutes ago and now
you're talking about monitors and what's
on your writer and I didn't you want to
talk to the sound crew and you a sound
check and he goes yeah no there's yeah
there's no monitor so he's looking at
you going like I don't know if you knew
but I'm a rock star
yeah and I know all rock songs right by
heart ten times over
yeah it's so heap it was over you were
like I was the rock fan comedian who
just asked the rock star
can I have monitors so I can
singing CDs and you know what what it's
a good thing it didn't happen and I'll
tell you why cuz the difference between
the Billy Joel moment was oh my god
what's going on I what I should not wait
what do you mean I'm going up on stage
oh my god
this my attitude here now as David
turned and started walking away I then I
went oh my god I got it I have to do
this I have to I'm gonna write down all
the lyrics and I'm gonna learn it before
I go and I went and I went to look for
him to go through them I mean I'm in I
got the lyrics and it was too late I was
too late if I did it that night hey I
know I would have brought the house down
but B I would have done it for the wrong
way I would have been I think my head
would have swelled quite a bit that
night I just feel like huh that was the
night of oh yeah you ready for this Dave
take a seat take a seat I know you're
huge but do all you guys take a rest I'm
gonna follow this I'm gonna no one play
I'm gonna I just want them to hear me I
feel like I wouldn't that would have
been in my head rather than just
enjoying the moment right I'm not
enjoying this moment anymore now I'm a
rock star
yes I felt it's like I truly feel and
I'm a rock star now Dave girls got me up
cuz he knows where as Dave Grohl is like
I just want to have some fun man and I
just wanna have some fun last week
Airport a seven-year-old tonight of the
show he's a goof yeah tomorrow I'm with
the king of you know in another country
I just it's a Cove I'm just trying to
help you try to have fun with Jim brewer
yeah that's true
you wanted it too much I wanted it you
wanted it too much
I did and you would have probably you
would sang it you would've done a
fabulous job
it would have had all the lyrics
everything would have gone well and then
you would have gone backstage and kind
of like nudged and angled about maybe
getting on the tour opener yeah actually
I thought that went really well like you
know I don't think that was a New York
thing out there man
that would work all over the country you
know I created I'm in this album couple
years ago it's pretty cool Rob Caggiano
used to be an anthro anyway check it out
man it's pretty good you know yeah that
was so it was a good thing it didn't
happen and I actually Dave Foo Fighters
came to a Metallica concert while we
were out on tour uh-huh and I remember
the city but our members they were
backstage and I had a live camera so
that people can see what's gonna big
screen so people could see what's going
on backstage for a burnick camera back
there and when I walked off to him like
Dave and Taylor wait can you guys do a
thing and he looked at me and he goes
well you know I asked you to do
something and you know he didn't really
come through on that nothing oh just
pour some salt in that and when I really
wanted that he said yeah Dave Grohl just
has the ability to embarrass you
he makes you say embarrassing things and
they and he didn't and again he's just
like a minute so far as I was looking
for my arms I can do it now watch this
in the beginning and he's looking at you
going like Jim the reason I asked you to
do it is because I thought we were on
the same level why you why you lower
yourself self like wait yeah but now I'm
with Metallica I was watching you know
part of the great thing about the
YouTube generation that we live in is
that I mean tons of your Metallica stuff
is on YouTube really have you seen it no
I cannot jim breuer opens - in this town
jim breuer opens in that no no no and I
was watching a little bit first of all I
thought it was just like amazing just
you being the fan that you are of
Metallica and metal in general yeah you
get to go on Metallica stage before they
come out and just play name that tune or
sing along with Pantera
get to play walk can I tell you that I
wanted to do there's so many things I
wanted to do on the tour there was
there's I wanted to do this bring real
people bring people from the audience up
and make a lighting show and give them a
karaoke metal moment and then I realized
from the game show once I would bring
people up and I had there were certain
shows ever do game shows and people
freeze on stage terrace they want to do
it and they're up on stage and they're
like oh god on the stage what Metallica
place and they're and they're looking at
the at the sheets and they're looking at
the equipment and then they and then
they realize oh my god is 15,000 people
staring at me and they're bowing there
boy just trying to get by this much and
I realize and everyone tried to talk me
out of don't bring them onstage don't
bring them onstage so I went back and
forth through it all right how about I
will go up there and we'll just we'll
sing along work I'll call it metal
karaoke hmm
and I we put together five songs on tops
45 seconds to a minute long and I gotta
say no disrespect to Pantera mm-hmm
I had no clue hands down that song walk
me was the I thought the roof was gonna
go flying off every arena yeah when that
song came on the entire arena with a tie
everyone on the floor would start
bouncing I mean that's one of those
songs that immediately as soon as you
hear like dent Dan and yeah like
everybody just just got goosebumps
yeah and so that and then you know the
ultimate is when it's over the last song
was a did Highway to Hell and the entire
arena because everyone knew that one of
course and that was definitely one of my
I would say I don't say best
yeah I'll say best that was the most
entertaining for me I couldn't wait to
do that every night because I'm like oh
you guys are gonna love what I'm gonna
do for you now and they did love it oh
they loved
I liked it like
you know I I think I've never I don't
know that I've ever seen it done before
you did crowd work but you went in the
crowd yes to do the crowd work like you
could go you see all these videos I was
watching one yeah we saw where you found
these these old guys one of them at like
a big white beard oh yeah yeah yeah and
you found them and like you know I'm
just kind of like flipping through the
YouTube video and like you just go up to
them and you're just on the floor but
the spotlights on you and you got the
microphone everybody can hear you and
they're older guys so you go hey you
guys get that colonoscopy is like huh
and you're like and they're like no no
colonoscopy and you're going alright
you're over 50 you got to get one and
that Brewer goes he goes he goes you
know it'll have you feeling clean right
after but a messy night before SEMA Dal
again there's Brewer just talking about
the benefits of a colonoscopy and the
fun I gotta say the funny moments like
that it was really cool to hear the
entire arena or most arena you hear the
laughter of it was and what I loved
about those moments was they're not
paying to see me there's comics out
there to sell out arenas and stadiums
and all that so they're paying to see
them mm-hmm nobody's paying a see Jim
Breuer along go to see Metallica so they
nobody's even paying to see comedy no
right no right so they already come in
with the honest fall and they walk out
like what is the hell's going on circus
Olay but yeah man that was that was a
real good time and and by the time it
was over I'm gonna say if they ever
asked me to do it again mmm-hmm it would
be even it's good I already got it's
gonna be ten times you ready to do it I
gotten completely I got ideas where I
know are gonna work that's now you know
what it is right I know what it is I
mean you walk in going like wow you just
go up
Aaron you know do your thing and you're
like yeah what do you mean now you know
exactly what the gig is I know what the
gig is I know the team to put around me
right to make it really work right and
and and I and you know I have to say
besides show one mm-hmm there wasn't one
night where they were like get the [ __ ]
off Thursday there may be people gone I
can't stand this guy mm-hmm but I've
played arenas before that they didn't
pay to see me and when a few people
start turning on you it turns into a
section right because they just love
[Laughter]
when you're fighting sections you're in
a bad place so do you go do you look at
that and then because you said it happen
night one do you looking like one
section starts going in do you go oh no
oh yeah this is gonna be contagious oh
yeah basically you're in the you're at
the circus when you go see the circus
yeah and you want that you want the lion
tamer to get eaten right of course you
do why you pay your ticket he's in the
cage
there's lions and circles all around all
he's got is a bullwhip mm-hmm and
section 105 is not trying to pawn and
now this line came off the dog get back
on the get back on the stove you're
gonna the other lines gonna be like wait
a minute
yeah we could repel the last thing you
want if one line you know you might be
able to deal with it but if all the
Lions start to become self-aware yes
well you're it's over you're done you
finished there's nothing you need to do
rebellion against you and even the first
show it wasn't sections it was it was
just bad timing right you know we went
up too early they said they were going
up at 8:30 they didn't go up at 8:30 out
of my got them all hopped up at 8:28
mm-hmm and then it was like we need 10
more missed
and they game ten minutes now they're
getting hostile right what we need at
least another five ten another coming
out yeah and that I remember uh the DJ
on stage gets your civvies on stage he's
call me why is on stage Jim come here
Jim come here I go I know I'm trying I
don't know what do you want me to do
they said they want me on stage it was
uh after that I learned like I we're not
gonna be in that particular yet right
well with all this going on you also
have a new album coming out tomorrow I
forgot I was even promoting that right
but that's what we're here for after all
clearly live from Portland comes out
tomorrow on all digital platforms you
recorded it at the helium comedy club in
Portland and Sam I swear to god yeah
this was not meant it wasn't planned
this wasn't supposed to be the album no
uh-huh well I wasn't even supposed to be
filming an album or recording an album
do you just record every set
I do record my sets about I don't
professionally audiotape and the videos
that you watch like on patreon or on my
on my social media stuff I have I call
him the kid he files me around he films
everything and when we were important
when we had a couple days off and we
were doing a food drive and we were
feeding homeless with some of the crew
uh-huh and I booked the room cuz we had
two nights off and I'm like ah you want
me booked because they said LF you
booked a club you know maybe we can ask
them to a food drive and we get more
food for that so it was all about
feeding homeless in Portland mm-hmm so I
called aphelion like hey can we get in
there bump get in there sold out was
which I was I'm always worried about
selling tickets and if you brought cans
of food I brought boxes of merchants to
take whatever you want
yeah we'll take twenty deviants to take
them it's all old stuff yeah I want him
out of house yes I want him out ask and
I did my set and I
I often wing the first 15 20 minutes
wherever I am and you know I've been
doing stuff
I've been I probably have two and a half
hours over the last two three years
maybe more and uh I didn't do stand-up
in a little while so which when I'm the
best so I'll do consistent tight sets
and then I'm off for a while and I get a
lot looser so I did the set and the end
the show he goes hey I just want you
know I I recorded tonight and I looked
at like no [ __ ] jackass I asked you to
videotape it and he goes no no I I it's
professionally recorded like through the
board and everything you know what okay
cool all right what does that do for me
like well I I got on my phone I'm gonna
listen to it later for my notes and he
goes yeah that's just I was I was really
good oh good I'm glad
and I was look good a 20 year old likes
me yeah and um about a month later a
manager goes we should make this an
album know what Portland because have
you listened to it
we know here's it's really good oh
really you you like you liked it because
I'm not even because you really need to
live he goes you ended but something
really pretty
it was thought-provoking was heavy and
it was hilarious
Oh what the hell did I end on they told
me what to enter oh I forgot I did that
that night he goes in the beginning you
did this whole thing about what what
Metallica tour is like and I went oh my
god forgot that which to this day I
forgot um I haven't even done that
material so you that was just that night
yes Wow
I do that a lot yeah and there was
always pardon this is why I started
filming everything I'm like you know
it's frustrating when I'm in Minnesota
and I do half hour of
off-the-cuff stuff and then I go in my
material and it just it's material
that's just gone forever
mhm and then I he goes you gotta listen
to it and I'm like Sam I listened for
three minutes I said it sounds amazing
that's all I cared about was the sound
like the audio quality
can you hear people laughing that's all
I care about and then I forgot about it
no it goes gonna be album and we're
gonna you know it's gonna be here like
okay cool
and then all of us you know all
sudden this week dog you got all this
press me that's a lot of press don't we
just let the elm go and he went no I'm
telling you this is more special than
you realize know what so you don't
necessarily remember everything that's
on the album but you're told it's very
very special correct okay I'm just being
honest I would say I worked so hard for
years I swear my life okay well I honest
I trust the people that you trust me too
right
yeah me too you know I don't around a
long time right and your managers not
gonna put something out that is bad cuz
he's managing you know any start a
record label just to get this out
there's like dude I'm just you sparked
me to this is amazing
yeah all right I trust you so the so he
started record labels just so he could
release this album well in others I mean
he's he's now but this was the catalyst
this was the first one on Serpico
records yeah man
well there must be something special
well we'll see yeah are you gonna listen
to it once it comes out or no you're
done no I'm done I'm working on this
other stuff there's nothing I could do
about that one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app